while it's easily one of the most
enjoyable installments in the MCU
Avengers endgame is anything but
straightforward failed with time travel
space aliens doppelgangers from the past
and a whole mess of magic rocks there
are plenty of moments in the film that's
simply confusing fortunately if there's
any part of the movie that makes you
scratch your head just wait five minutes
chances are good someone involved in a
production will give an interview that
attempts to straighten it all out case
in point sibling filmmakers Joe and
Anthony Russo got candid with business
insider about the endgame scene
featuring a past version of the
otherwise dead Norse gods Loki while
Iron Man ant-man professor Hulk and
Captain America return to New York City
in 2012 to collect the tesseract and
Loki's scepter which held the space
stone and the mind stone respectively
Loki swiftly grub's the tesseract and
the escapes Sora's custody through a
portal once he's gone
that's pretty much the last anyone sees
of Loki in Avengers endgame so what went
down where is Loki now according to
co-director Joe Russo Loki is still dead
in the core Marvel Cinematic Universe
timeline is capturing of the space stone
in 2012 doesn't reverse as Infinity Ward
death at the hands of Thanos
but he is alive in a different pocket of
the universe Loki snatching the stone
and beaming away created a unique
timeline that more or less falls in line
with a conversation between Professor
Hulk and the ancient one and the two met
to discuss him borrowing the time stone
essentially Loki's escaped but the space
stone was significant enough to cause
the central timeline to break off into a
branched reality the filmmaker explained
Loki when he teleports away with the
space stone would create his own
timeline it gets very complicated but it
would be impossible for cap to rectify
the timeline unless he found Loki the
minute that Loki does something as
dramatic as take the space stone he
creates a branched reality now Tony
Stark and Steve Rogers did wind up
getting their hands on the space stone
by utilizing the last of their available
Pym particles to travel to 1970 steel
the space stone from shield and then
snag a few more vials of particles from
Hank Pimm's lab so they could return
home again this allowed them to fulfill
their time heist mission and load up
their own Infinity Gauntlet in the Year
2023
to revive the heroes who were killed at
the end of infinity war but that didn't
fix the problem of there being a Loki
somewhere out there with the space stone
he stole in 2012 the final moments of
endgame saw cap returning all six
Infinity stones to their rightful places
and times and
the case of the space stone he took that
one back to the shield base in 1970 not
to New York in 2012 it's confusing
like Rousseau mentioned but the truth of
the matter is that taking the tesseract
from and returning it to 1970 doesn't
affect a low-key snagging it in 2012
at least not according to the
time-travel standards by which endgame
operates somebody peed my pants time
travel as of now past Loki is living it
up with the space stone in an alternate
timeline he isn't the same character fan
saw tried to kind of redeem himself in
Thor the dark world he isn't the same
one in foretellers army in thor ragnarok
and then died an Avengers infinity war
either this is pre Redemption arc Loki a
Loki who is still a villain who tried to
ravage earth on behalf of Thanos the
door is open for this Loki to return to
the cinematic universe in a future film
but it's more likely that evil 2012 Loki
will first rear his head on his
standalone streaming series headed to
Disney Plus Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige has noted that the Disney
Plus superhero series which also include
one division and the Winter Soldier
Falcon team-up show will quote
intersects with the movies in a very big
way suggesting that Loki sneaky getaway
an end game could shape everything about
his forthcoming TV series it's unclear
when the project will hit the surface so
fans are xx time to speculate about how
the series we'll explore Loki's
alternate timeline as he being an
all-out baddie and asking strangers to
bend the knee to him or is he taking a
more subtle approach to villainy kicking
back while he chills us both on a throne
somewhere either seems plausible and the
plot points would be down to see unfold
on the Loki series check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos about the MCU are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you